Новий ранець, пенал, зошити, щоденник.
Що саме потрібно першокласнику Нової української школи,
його мамі Анні Куницький ніхто не повідомив,
тому купувала все на власний розсуд.
Каже, на батьківських зборах суть шкільної реформи,
нову програму навчання чи підручники ніхто не пояснював. Натомість…
- Був чомусь головний наголос на збір грошей,
а не на те, яка шкілька програма. Ось теж дивно:
чомусь ніхто не говорив ні про підручники, взагалі нічого.
НУШ і все. Гроші несіть - ось це головне.
Понад один мільярд гривень ще 7 місяців тому
виділила держава на фінансування Нової української школи.
Це гроші не на ремонт класів, а на нові меблі,
навчальні матеріали та обладнання, такі як принтер,
проектор, ламінатор. За задумом міністерства, усі,
навіть найвіддаленіші сільські початкові школи
до першого вересня мали отримати цей однаковий комплект навчальних засобів.
На практиці вийшло інакше.
Навіть не всі столичні школи отримали обіцяне.
- А от ми чекаємо, що ще дошка прийде.
Головна причина - неспроможність місцевої влади
зібратися і проголосувати за розподіл грошей.
Звідси - затримка з оголошеннями тендерів та виробництва.
Станом на середину серпня загалом по Україні
використано менше половини державних субвенцій
на Нову українську школу.
Тобто половина українських першачків 1 вересня
не побачать ні інтерактивної дошки, ні мобільних парт,
ні ігрових матеріалів, як, приміром, конструктори "Лего",
якими так вихвалялися чиновники.
До того ж, через неякісну роботу Інституту модернізації змісту освіти
зірвався план друку підручників для учнів нової школи.
- У першому класі підручники появляться у жовтні.
Для вересня в першому класі
матеріали всі вчителі отримають,
в електронному вигляді...
...і будуть працювати так, як треба.
Утім, у перший місяць школи першачкам не доведеться
сидіти лише за партами. Це адаптаційний місяць і
навчання відбуватиметься радше в ігровій формі.
Це все прописано в новій освітній програмі.
- Моя мрія... Досягнення... Як я себе оцінюю.
А таке індивідуальне портфоліо
слугуватиме школярикам за щоденник.
У столичній школі, яка вже з минулого року
в тестовому режимі навчалася за проектом НУШ,
розповідають, що навіть великий ранець дітям не потрібен.
Усі навчальні засоби можна залишати в класі.
Удома вони не знадобляться, бо домашніх завдань у перших класах не буде.
Класичних уроків від дзвінка до дзвінка теж не буде:
учитель на власний розсуд робитиме перерви.
- Зараз ми маємо право, якщо я бачу, що втрачена увага
чи дітки втомилися,
...ми можемо вийти на подвір'я і продовжити роботу.
Аби програма НУШ жила не лише на папері,
усі 22 тисячі українських вчителів початкових класів
протягом минулого року відвідували відповідне навчання.
Успіх реформи великою мірою залежить саме від їхніх підходів.
- Це не буде просто, але
зате цікаво.
Цікаво побачити результат, цікаво побачити,
як діти сприйматимуть усе це
Батькам також радять ознайомитися
з новою навчальною програмою, яка є
в відкритому доступі в інтернеті.
Так вони зможуть контролювати і вчителів, і дітей.
Окрім того, від батьків першачків, таких, як Анна,
очікують, що вони пильнуватимуть, на що витрачаються шкільні кошти,
і повідомлятимуть про випадки корупції.
Бо поборам у Новій українські школі не місце.